[Music]
2.5 million terabytes that's how much
data the world creates every day storing
organizing and analyzing data is
becoming more important than ever and
data engineers build the engines that
help companies make sense of it all they
are crucial to any company's data
strategy without the right
infrastructure you can collect data but
it just sits it takes up space that's
why our team at Udacity created the data
engineer nano degree program in a
flexible learning environment we teach
you how to understand the data ecosystem
then give you the right tools to
navigate it you apply what you learn by
completing hands on portfolio ready
projects along with the world-class
curriculum that you get with a nano
degree program you also gain access to a
career services to help you succeed so
are you ready to help the world find
meaning out of data join today by
enrolling in the data engineer
[Music]